hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today we're going to talk about the
eigen states of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the energy of a
quantum particle in a harmonic
oscillator as you know is quantized
today we're going to build the
corresponding eigenstates both in an
abstract way in terms of creation
operators and also in a very concrete
way in terms of wave functions
we will also look at their mathematical
form which is quite interesting because
these wave functions are the product of
a gaussian
and a polynomial called a hermit
polynomial and we will also create some
visualizations for these wave functions
so let's go the hamiltonian operator for
the quantum permanent oscillator
is given by the kinetic energy which is
proportional to the momentum squared
plus the potential energy which is
proportional to the position squared
we can also rewrite this hamiltonian in
terms of the ladder operators
or in terms of the number operator
the eigenvalue equation for the
hamiltonian is this
where e sub n are the energy eigenvalue
and n the energy eigenstates
in the video on the eigenvalues of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
we find that en is given by this
expression
where n can only take one of the values
0
1 2 and so on in integer steps
to understand what this means we can
draw the real axis
and we're now going to draw the allowed
values of the energy on this axis
the lowest possible energy corresponds
to n equals zero
and it is one half times h bar omega
here
the fact that the lowest energy that the
system can have
is not zero is a feature of quantum
particles and is radically different to
the classical case
where a particle can be at rest in a
harmonic potential with zero energy
this lowest energy is typically called
the zero point energy of the system
the next allowed value is for n equals
one
and it is three halves times h bar omega
here the next one is here
and so on the allowed energy levels are
separated by an energy h-bar omega
which is called a quantum of energy
let's make some room in the diagram
something else we also learn in the
video on the quantum harmonic oscillator
eigenvalues
is that the ladder operators allow us to
move between energy eigenstates
in particular the raising operator
allows us to increase the energy by
one quantum at a time and the lowering
allows us to go the other way
and finally the number operator allows
us to count
how many energy quanta there are in the
system above
the zero point energy
okay so this was our quick refresher on
the energy levels of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
and for more details you should check
the corresponding videos that are
linked in the description what i want to
do today is to consider the
eigen states here we'll see how we can
construct them
and calculate their explicit form in the
position representation
that is we'll calculate the wave
functions of the harmonic oscillator
that are associated with the allowed
energy levels
okay so let's start with some results
that we obtained in the video on the
lateral number operators
the action of the raising operator a
dagger on an energy eigenstate
n is equal to the square root of n plus
one
times the eigen state n plus one
we therefore see that the action of the
raising operator is simply to pick an
eigenstate
n of the system and then add a quantum
of energy h-bar omega
to generate a new eigenstate of the
system n
plus 1. this relation is true
for any n and in particular it will be
true for n minus 1
and it becomes this we can now invert
this equation to write
the state n in terms of the state n
minus 1.
again this expression is valid for any n
so we can write the state n
minus 1 in terms of the state n minus 2
like this we can now pick
this state n minus 1 and insert it into
this
expression doing this we end up with the
state
n in terms of the state in minus 2.
you can now imagine how we can continue
doing this all the way to the ground
state n equals zero
and we end up with this
we can simplify this expression by
grouping the terms in the pre-factor
to write the eigenstate n of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
as equal to 1 over square root of n
factorial times
a dagger to the power of n acting on
the ground state 0.
let's consider this expression for a
moment
all it is saying is that to generate the
eigenstate
n which is the eigenstate with n energy
quanta
above the ground state we simply need to
apply the raising operator
n times on the ground state but this
makes perfect sense because each
application of the racing operator adds
an energy quantum so if we want n energy
quanta
we need to apply a dagger in times the
only role of this prefactor here is to
ensure normalization
that is if the ground state 0 is
normalized
then the prefactor ensures that the
eigenstate n is
also normalized so these are the energy
eigenstates of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
what we'll do in the rest of the video
is to write down the wave functions
associated with these eigenstates
which essentially means writing them
down in the position representation
we'll use multiple results about the
position representation of both
states and operators so if you're not
familiar with them make sure that you
first
check out the corresponding videos that
are linked in the description
let's start with the ground state we
know from the video on the energy
eigenvalues of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
that when we act with the lowering
operator on the ground state of the
system
we get zero and we kill the state
we also know from the video on ladder
operators
that we can write the lowering operator
in terms of the position
and momentum operators and doing so we
get
this so this is the equation that we're
going to work with
and we can immediately divide through by
1 over square root of 2
to remove this factor what we want to do
next
is to rewrite this equation in the
position representation
again you can find all the details in
the corresponding videos linked in the
description
but all we need to know is to remember
that in the position representation
the position operator acting on a state
psi gives
x multiplying the corresponding wave
function
and the momentum operator acting on a
state psi gives
i h bar times that derivative with
respect to
x of the wave function
using these results we can pick this
equation up here
multiply it by square root of m omega
over h bar
and we can rewrite it in the position
representation like this
in this step i've decided to call the
ground state wave function
psi zero feel free to stop here for a
second to make sure that you
are happy with this step
so this is our next task to solve this
differential equation
to find an explicit form for the ground
state
wave function this is a simple first
order differential equation so it's
relatively easy to solve
we can first rearrange the equation to
separate the variables
we can then integrate both sides with
respect to x
the left-hand side gives the logarithm
of psi
0 and the right-hand side gives this
pre-factor
multiplying x squared and then we have
an integration constant
c exponentiating we find
that the ground state wave function is
equal to a times the exponential of
minus m
omega x squared over two h bar
this a constant here is simply e to the
power of the original integration
constant
so the ground state wave function of the
harmonic oscillator is a gaussian
as a quick aside this result here also
shows that the ground state of the
quantum harmonic oscillator is
non-degenerate
because the solution of a first order
differential equation
like the one for psi zero is unique
so all we have left to do is to
determine the normalization constant
a to do so we're going to insist that
one
is equal to the integral overall space
of the wave function squared
we can next insert the form of the wave
function that we just got
and at this stage we're going to use
this standard gaussian integral
integrals like this one are very common
and you can find them tabulated in most
resources including wikipedia
so it's good to solve them directly at
least once but most of the time we just
look them up when we need them and this
is exactly what i'm doing
here so using this result and realizing
that this constant
alpha in our case is given by this
expression
we can now rewrite the integral as equal
to this
and isolating the normalization constant
we get this
finally a is equal to this
where i've made a simple face choice to
ensure that the normalization is real
and this is it our final expression for
the ground state wave function of the
system is given by this pre-factor
times this exponential
for now we'll just leave this result as
is and move on to
calculate the eigenfunctions
corresponding to other energy
eigenvalues
but we'll come back to this wave
function later in the video to explore
its features
in some more detail
calculating the wavefunctions of the
higher energy levels is conceptually
straightforward
all we need to do is to use the result
we derived earlier
relating the eigenstate n here with the
ground state here
the raising operator can be written in
terms of the position and
momentum operators like this
and just like we did earlier for the
lowering operator we can also rewrite it
in the position representation
with this result we can rewrite this
equation up here
in the position representation we have
that the eigenfunction corresponding to
energy level
n is equal to this pre-factor
then the rating operator in the position
representation
we have to apply it n times and all of
this acting on the ground state eigen
function
we just calculated what this ground
state wave function
is so we can insert it here and we get
this long expression
all i've done is to insert the
expression for psi 0 and also extracted
these factors of 2 here and here
and group them here
so these are the energy eigenfunctions
of the quantum harmonic oscillator
i haven't explicitly calculated them but
using this formula we can calculate any
eigenfunction that we're interested in
for an arbitrary n
as an example let's consider the first
excited state
for which n equals one using the general
expression up here we have this
prefactor
times this bracket
acting on the exponential if we focus on
this part
for now the first term is simply this
factor
times the exponential and
the second is this factor times the
derivative of the exponential
we can rearrange this expression
to this
inserting it back into a full expression
we get
this for the first excited state energy
eigenfunction
we can of course repeat this exercise to
get any excited state n
but as you can probably imagine the math
becomes a little tedious
what we find is that each excited state
n
has the general form of a pre-factor
times a polynomial of order
n times the gaussian exponential
so from this expression we can calculate
any energy eigenfunction cyan
of the quantum harmonic oscillator this
expression that we just derived can in
fact be written in a number of
alternative but mathematically
equivalent ways
in the video on hermit polynomials that
is linked in the description
we show how to rewrite it in one of its
most common forms
here i'm just going to quote the answer
which is that
psi n of x is equal to this pre-factor
multiplying this function h n
times this exponential
the hn functions are polynomials of
order n
called hermit polynomials we investigate
some of the properties in the
corresponding video
but the most important for our purposes
now is that hermit polynomials have
definite parity according to this
relation
if we look back at the energy
eigenstates then we see that they are
the product of
one of these hermit polynomials and a
gaussian
as the gaussian is an even function then
the energy eigenfunctions have the same
parity as that
of the hermit polynomials which
essentially means
that for even n we have even states
and for odd n we have odd states
now we could have expected this result
because the hamiltonian operator of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
commutes with the parity operator which
means that the hamiltonian is an even
operator we then know from the video on
even and odd operators
that the eigen states of the hamiltonian
must also be
eigen states of the parity operator
which
means that they must have definite
priority as we've just confirmed
overall we can use this expression at
the top
or this expression here in terms of
hermit polynomials to construct an
arbitrary
energy eigenfunction what we'll do to
finish is to plot some of these
eigenfunctions to see what they look
like
the diagram on the left shows the ground
state wavefunction
i want to focus on the shape of the
wavefunctions so i'll be using arbitrary
units
and i have not included specific values
on the axes
as we determined earlier in this video
the ground state is proportional to a
gaussian function
and as such it is an even function
the diagram on the right shows the
absolute value squared
of the wave function a quantity that
gives the probability density of the
particle position
so that in the ground state the particle
is most likely to be found
at the center of the harmonic potential
this next diagram on the left is the
first excited state wave function
we also determined it earlier in this
video and it is a gaussian
multiplied by x so overall it is an
odd function in the right diagram we see
that the probability of finding the
particle at the center of the harmonic
potential
is zero while the particle is most
likely to be found
at this point or this other point
this on the left is the second excited
state which is an
even function as expected
the probability density on the right now
has three peaks
with the central one being smaller than
the side ones
and here i have again the ground state
first excited state and second excited
state in the first row
and in the second row i have added three
more excited states
as you can see when we increase the
value of n
we get more zeros in our wave function
because it is given by a polynomial
of increasing order you can also see
pictorially the parity properties of
each wave function
the corresponding absolute values
squared wave functions behave
as you would expect as shown here
and finally here i have the wave
function and its absolute value squared
for a very large value of n
in this case n equals 60.
you can see that the probability density
approaches a limit in which the particle
is most
likely to be found at the extremes of
the harmonic potential here
and here and least likely to be found at
the center of the potential
here this result is consistent with the
classical limit in the
sense that the extrema of the potential
are the turning points of a classical
particle undergoing harmonic motion
where it is momentarily at rest so it
spends a large fraction of its time
there and by contrast the center is
where the classical particle is moving
really fast
so it spends a small fraction of its
time there
the eigenstates of the quantum harmonic
oscillator are the building blocks to
study a wide range of quantum systems
so mathematical form is rather involved
but at the same time they have some
rather interesting properties for
example
the wave functions are even or odd which
reflects
the inversion symmetry of the potential
as a next step you can learn more about
the mathematical form of these wave
functions by checking out our video
on hermit polynomials or you can learn
more about the behavior of particles in
the quantum harmonic oscillator by
checking out our video on coherent
states and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe